planning to renovate your bathroom pay
close attention first you need to
measure and draft your existing space
second plan your works and make the
space come to life long before you start
smashing [ __ ] third make it happen today
we focus on part one to measure your
space you'll need a piece of paper and a
pencil if you're a little bougie like me
you can use an ipad combined with the
morpholio trace app make sure you
measure everything you'll need to know
the details when planning it out plaster
to plaster floor to ceiling window
heights and window widths door frames
and door panels don't forget the center
line of fixtures and the overall
dimensions keep in mind where light
switches and power points are too you
might need to relocate them later when
you're done you should end up with
something like this now that you have
the existing information and paper we
can take this into archicad and draft
our existing space what's going on guys
my name is david tomic welcome back to
the channel the first video of 2022
is definitely going to be an exciting
one so i'm not going to waste too much
of your time we're going to jump
straight into arcad and start modelling
our existing bathroom space all right so
we have our arcad 25 template open and
we're going to start modelling our
bathroom first of all let's start by
simply drawing the fill tool to actually
be able to indicate where things need to
go clicking to start our fill tool i can
start typing in two one
five zero tab button one eight zero zero
which makes the overall shape of my
bathroom toilet next to it is 900
millimeters wide by again 1.8 meters
long so if i indicate that there command
d and move it over 110 millimeters for
that partition wall i can see that is
the foundation of my bathroom in total
so now if i come across to our wall tool
make sure we change our wall layer from
walls external towards internal and
change to a 90 millimeter stud partition
wall we can then basically draw around
the outside of our perimeter
and create the overall shape of our
bathroom relatively quickly now i can
select both these by holding shift and
pressing the delete button to be able to
indicate the overall size and shape of
my bathroom now if i highlight all of
these walls go command t i could open
them up and i can then change my story
settings to not linked and change the
overall ceiling height of 2.7 meters as
we measured in the actual bathroom now
clicking ok and going into our 3d object
we can see that we've started to create
our bathroom itself obviously at the
moment it's just walls nothing special
so we'll come back into our ground floor
select them all command t and we're
going to override all of our surfaces
with a white fine texture
so it is just white plasterboard going
back into our ground floor plan i
usually like to start with the doors and
the windows so we'll go to our door tool
go to door settings at the top you can
also press command t if you want we're
going to start with our toilet door on
the left hand side which is simply a 620
wide door itself it's a very basic door
there's nothing special about it but i
will quickly change the overall line
type so it isn't orange straight to
black pressing okay i can then tuck that
door hard up against the wall itself and
then holding the alt button i can
simply drop that door randomly in the
side to be able to open up the settings
once more by pressing command t
searching for a pocket door at the top i
can use pocket door 25 i'm going to make
it just a very simple plain door coming
into my nominal sizes i'm going to make
that 820 wide and changing my leaf to
720
makes it the overall perfect size so
clicking ok
we have our pocket sliding door over
here now now i think i've made an
overall error in my calculation so i've
had to go back and double check the
measurement that isn't two one five zero
in fact it is
three one five zero so that makes it a
significantly bigger space than i
originally thought and i can realign
that door to one one four zero minus
which looks a lot more like what we have
in the bathroom at the moment so it's
very very important that you cross check
all your dimensions and go back and
cross check again if you ever think
there is an uncertainty or any doubt in
your design so far last but not least
what we need is our window so if i come
into my window tool at the top select my
window type in sliding i can use my two
sliding window for the time being it's a
single sliding window that we have
and it is 970 wide 540 wide with a sill
height of
154 centimeters overall same thing as
the door going to change both those line
weights to black and we are going to
place that in to our bathroom right
there now if we come back into 3d we
will see that we've started to create
the bathroom that we have right now as
it stands at the moment all we have is
some walls some doors so we're going to
come back in and start modeling the
actual bathroom features before we go
too far i'm going to control t on that
door go to model attributes at the top
and change all of this to white so if i
paint everything titanium white that'll
be exactly like what's shown right now
in the bathroom i'll do the same thing
for this swing door here and i'll change
the window frame settings to match
what's in the bathroom as well and there
we go now we have three openings in this
bathroom that allow us to continue
creating and drafting our existing
building coming back into the ground
floor plan pressing control down arrow
we can create our footings layer here go
minus 172 millimeters and click ok
if i right click on the ground and go
show as trace reference i can then
simply select my slab tool and create a
slab underneath that bathroom there by
clicking ctrl t or command t we can
change it to a tiled top
so 100 structural concrete plus tiled
finish
and changing the top layer to tiles matt
150 by 150 is fine for the purposes of
this coming back into 3d we'll see that
they're slightly floating a bit so
command or control d lifting it up to
the underside
and now we have our tyres coming all the
way into our bathroom if we come back
into our footings layout press control
or command up and use our marquee tool
select the dark aligned marquee and then
highlight everything but the two
external walls in this situation i'm
selecting these two right click show
marquee in 3d we can get a bit more of a
cut axonometric of what we're actually
trying to achieve and look at so it
makes it a bit easier to see inside
going back to our ground floor plan
hitting escape a couple of times to get
rid of that marquee space we can start
introducing our cabinetry so if we come
across to our object tool go open object
we can type in vanity and our basin
cabinet 25 will come up so selecting
basin cabinet 25 quickly overriding all
of our lines so they go to black and we
can actually understand what's going on
we can then change our dimensions to
1956
and overall height of 790.
now looking at this cabinetry we're not
too far off straight away it's very
similar to what we have in the bathroom
but we'll continue working through the
settings to be able to actually apply it
as what we see now i'm going to
introduce that vanity into this space
command d perfectly in to the corner
where it sits if i jump back to my 3d
marquee now we'll see that that vanity
has been placed into our space and we
are getting closer and closer to what is
actually seen in the bathroom now if we
also want to introduce our mirror all we
have to do is command d command once
more and command t to open up our
settings type in mirror use our mirror
25 go rectangle we don't want to frame
whatsoever because we know it is
frameless and our mirror is the same
width as our vanity overall which means
it is 190 millimeters wide and it is a
total of 908 tall so if i click ok
then we can relocate that perfectly
above our vanity basin now we can focus
on two more elements that are left in
this bathroom which is the shower and
the toilet themselves so let's start
simply by going to object tool object
typing in toilet because it is one of
the easiest objects to place in
let's go water closet 25
and click ok straight away dropping that
into our space and centering it in the
middle so that is 900 wide 450 centers
it gives us our toilet as we have it
right now in that space finally we want
to come to our object tool go object
come across to shower and use our shower
cabin 25 now we're not going to worry
too much about all the shower details in
this because we're going to be
demolishing it completely so what we're
going to have to do is change our
overall dimensions here one meter and 10
centimeters and one meter and nine
centimeters
because we have a three a 200 mil hob we
also change
that in our shower tray settings the
tray thickness 200 which for us is
already conveniently set
and pressing okay so dropping that
shower in rotating command e 90 degrees
and dropping it in to our shower now if
we then come across to our 3d marquee
we'll see that we've introduced our
shower which is the wrong way around so
coming back in command m selecting the
center holding shift and mirroring that
shower all the way we will get our
shower coming in properly we are missing
one last thing which is a 200 millimeter
upstand of tiles so i'll quickly create
a wall tool use an internal wall
press command t to open up the settings
change it to a basic structural
composition change the overall wall
settings to tiles give it a 10
millimeter thickness and change the
overall structure to tiles 150 150 so it
matches the wall then all we want to do
is make sure it is not linked
give it a 200 millimeter high overall
size and ensure that we're drawing on
the inside of our plasterboard as best
as we can so simply following all the
way around making sure we start and stop
in the right places our 200 millimeter
upstand tile all the way around our
bathroom now if we go back to our 3d
marquee we'll see that we haven't marked
that extra 10 millimeters because it's
offset off the wall so we'll see our
actual tile upstand come into play if we
were to go into a little bit more detail
we would also show the tiles in this
shower cubicle as they are all the way
to 2.1 so if we come back to our ground
floor plan
use our tile here holding the alt button
to replicate the settings
and drawing a line all the way around
the side we can select those two walls
and go to 2.1 meters high so now if we
come back to our 3d we'll see those
tiles uh all the way up to the top
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video if you did make
sure you smash the like button and the
subscribe button and like always i'll
see you next monday